freedom is rare authoritarianism is
common so i was looking at some uh
statistics that uh 53 percent of people
in the world
live under authoritarian government so
only 53.
oh because india is is democratic so i
guess they don't count india but yeah
yes
so it used to be a hundred how do we
change it exactly yeah
how do we change that and even the
authoritarianism in a country like
china is a lot less
than it used to be under mao right so so
i would i would
you know they were better off than they
were tomorrow that's a reality
how do we change it we have to
declare we have to change the ethical
views of people this
brings us back to selfishness it because
it it as long as the standard of
morality
is the group others as long as the
standard of value is what other people
want what other people think
as long as you are alive only to be
sacrificed to the group that's why
you have to challenge christianity as
long as
the the the jesus on a cross dying for
other people sin
is viewed as this noble wonderful act
instead of one of the most unjust things
to ever happen to anybody
as long as the common good and the
public interest are the standards by
which we evaluate things
we will always drift towards fascism
some form of authoritarianism
can i ask you a question i think there's
something that has to go along with what
jaron was saying and i know he's going
to agree with me which is technology
because if it becomes harder
technologically for the authoritarian
and
more expensive for him to input or force
his edicts
that is going to create a pocket of
freedom regardless of what the masses
think and the masses says hold on let me
finish the masses as a rule are not
going to be able to think in general
anyway i i
have a much more elitist view of mankind
than randos so let me give you one
specific example which i mentioned in my
book than you write
let's suppose it's 1990 not that long
ago we all remember 1990
and we're having an argument about
censorship and euron says i want full
sense full freedom of
the press freedom of books publish
whatever you want whatever free free
speech and i say well
what about books like mineconf what
about you know people read this to the
wrong idea
what about child pornography things like
this like where are you going to draw
the line and we could argue along
lex appears from the future and he goes
hey guys
this conversation is moot and we're like
lex you look
exactly the same i'm like yeah of course
robots don't age and you go
i'm from the future and i go wait i'm in
a black president
and you go look this conversation is
moot because in a few years from now
you will be able to send any book
anywhere on earth
at the speed of light you can make
infinite copies
at in one second and you could send it
to anyone such that
they can only open this book if they
know a magic word
and i go well how much is this going to
cost oh it's free and i go wait you're
telling me
i can make infinite copies of any book
and teleport them
at the speed of light anywhere for free
and you would say yes
we would think he's insane but that's
the status quo right
so technology has done far more to fight
government censorship of literature and
ideas
than has spreading the right ideas so
when you have things like
crypto which makes money less accessible
than a gold block in your house
when you have things like people being
able to travel quickly those are also
necessary uh compliments to having the
right ideas
and rent herself said that she couldn't
have come up with her philosophy before
the industrial revolution
so as time goes forward and we have more
technology
and we have more discourse but for deaf
very different
sure but it's also a lot easier to
persuade people the right ideas
so i kind of agree i i'm maybe i'm more
pessimistic or maybe i don't get the
technology completely
um that's cause you're a boomer there
you go
okay i get that
yeah i think i'm the last year of the
boomer generation
i think i hit that last year it's a
mindset there you go um
i love you so much so the reason she
said she couldn't have developed her
the reason she said she couldn't develop
the philosophy without the industrial
evolution
is the link between reason
and wealth was not obvious before the
industrial revolution
and that you know for example it's not
obvious to aristotle aristotle doesn't
see the link between rationality
and wealth creation business is low uh
you know and and money is uh money is
bad yeah money is your interest has no
productive function bankers don't have
so uh so you had to see it existentially
to be able to see
reason is the source of wealth creation
um
so i think that's a little different now
there is a sense in which
yes technology makes it more difficult
for authoritarians
to achieve their authoritarianism i i
wouldn't i'm not convinced that they
can't
if that's they can't yeah okay they
can't yeah so you know
at a certain point it's not the
electricity i'm just saying it becomes
more expensive
it becomes more expensive no question it
becomes more expensive and
we're still beings that live in a
physical reality
uh therefore they can still harm us in
in this physical reality
but let me say this like it's gonna
sound as absurd if there was technology
that
we could teleport anywhere on earth at
the speed of light oh sure that would
certainly do go a long way
towards uh hurting authorities sure if
there was some way to go yeah
and sure because they could teleport too
sure and and this is of course the
danger of
of of they can use the technology too
sure and look at what the chinese are
doing with social scores and
and uh and with monitoring people and
cameras everywhere so there's a sense in
which you probably had more privacy
uh before some of the technology so so
it's not
obvious to me a so to me it's all about
ideas
uh and if we don't get the ideas right
technology will be used for evil
yes and it will allow some of us maybe
to escape for a little while
in in some realms but others not uh
you know iran and and north korea do a
pretty good job shutting themselves away
from technology
uh although a lot gets through in the
iranian
at least with iran i don't know i don't
know about north korea how much gets to
it's real undermining them
which is wonderful yeah which is great
uh so so yes and but it's it's more than
that
and this is what leads me to be
optimistic it's that we live in a world
today
where seven billion people basically
have access to all of human knowledge
all of human knowledge it's not like in
rome when rome fell
all of human knowledge disappeared now
some of it escaped to byzantine some of
the byzantines had and ultimately land
up with the arabs and
found its way back into western
civilization through them but
a lot of knowledge disappeared just
wiped out right how to build a dome how
to build a big dome
how to have you know in pompeii they had
faucets that running water
wow in faucets they didn't have fossils
for another thousand years
right um a lot of they couldn't build
tall buildings
yeah once rome came down the great
pyramid of egypt
was the tallest building on earth until
like 1840s yeah crazy rome was a city of
a million people
other than china there wasn't another
city of a million people in the west
until london in the 19th century 1500
years later
so it all disappeared because all of it
was concentrated basically in one place
today none of that exists because of the
internet because because of in
universities everywhere institutions i
mean think about how many engineers they
are in the world today
who have basically all different
basically the same level of knowledge on
how to build stuff
so even if the united states went to
some kind of dark ages
it's unlikely the whole world goes into
that kind of dark ages so i i
am optimistic in that sense that
diffusion of knowledge
is so broad today that other other than
wiping out all electricity on the planet
everything electronic on the planet
it's just it's not going to be possible
to control us all and there's and in
that sense technology
is going to make it possible for us to
survive and to stay
semi-free because i don't think full
freedom but semi-free because for
freedom you need the ideas
because for freedom means you need some
political implementation no
full freedom means anarchy but we know
that no well
we need to get into that because we
can't leave without pointing out that we
fundamentally disagree about
you